it looks like there's a new predator
movie in the works and I have only one
thing to say command do it command I'm
Simon and this is your entertainment
news update a new predator movie is on
the way directed and co-written by iron
man 3 Shane Black titled the predator
has now been confirmed that the film
will begin production this fall black
was recently at the Cannes Film Festival
to promote his new comedy thriller the
nice guys as reported by AVP galaxy
black told Agence france-presse that
production on the predator would begin
in the latter part of the full black
also repeated his earlier comments that
the new movie would be on a far bigger
scale than the previous films in the
long-running sci-fi action franchise to
the best of my knowledge the train is
rolling it took some convincing because
they've been putting out these movies
all along with the 50 to 60 million
dollar budget and they all had a
guaranteed return in March black spoke
to thrillist about how he became
involved with the predator and what fans
could expect they called me and I was
reluctant I said look you guys are Fox I
mean I enjoy these movies but we've been
churning out these AVP whatever they
each cost a certain amount of money
they're okay but there's no effect to
elevate them or make them any kind of
event they said what if we said to you
we want to reinvent this and really
treat it with as much of an event status
or as much hoopla as we would the alien
prequel we really want to make this
something i think that they came to me
knowing pretty much that they said
basically if I wanted to make predator
but treat it like it was iron man 3
instead of just another little movie I
said let's really do it right this time
black himself appeared in the original
predator the 1987 smash starring arnold
schwarzenegger and directed by john
mctiernan to date there have been for
further films including the direct
sequel predator 22 alien vs predator
movies and 2010 s robert rodriguez
produced predators the predator is set
to be released on March the second 2018
and then it will be time to get to the
choppa let me know what you think about
the new predator either in the comments
or come find me on Twitter
i'm at the Jagan or thanks for watching
and for all your entertainment news keep
it gamespot
you